It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans start at $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢忙碌的时候，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. When you're stressed or overwhelmed, do you ever just go for a walk to clear your head? Many of us feel intuitively that nature is good for us. We know that spending time outside among trees or near the water can help us feel calmer, clearer, and more focused. Now a growing body of research is proving our intuitions right. Psychologists and other researchers have found that access to nature is critical to people's mental and physical health. and in an age of constant distractions, they're also finding that spending time in nature can help us recapture our powers of focus and concentration. So what is it about natural environments that is so
Google Fi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不会受到数据流量降速的影响。当你感到压力或不知所措时，你会不会去散散步来清醒一下头脑？我们许多人凭直觉感到大自然对我们有益。我们知道，在树木丛中或水边待上一段时间可以帮助我们感到更平静、更清醒、更专注。现在，越来越多的研究证明了我们的直觉是正确的。心理学家和其他研究人员发现，接触大自然对人们的身心健康至关重要。而且在充满干扰的时代，他们还发现，在大自然中度过时光可以帮助我们找回专注力和注意力。那么，自然环境究竟有什么
beneficial for our brains? Do we need to spend time in unspoiled forests or on hiking trails to see these effects, or can city trees and parks work just as well? What can you do to interior spaces like your home to make them feel more natural. What if you're not an outdoorsy person? Do you have to enjoy spending time in nature to benefit from it? And what implications does this research have for policymakers, urban planners, and others who shape our physical world? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology,
对我们的大脑如此有益呢？我们需要在原始森林或徒步小径上度过时光才能看到这些效果吗？还是说城市里的树木和公园也能起到同样的作用？你可以对室内空间（比如你的家）做些什么，让它们感觉更自然？如果你不是一个喜欢户外活动的人怎么办？你必须喜欢在大自然中度过时光才能从中受益吗？这项研究对政策制定者、城市规划者和其他塑造我们物理世界的人有什么启示？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，
the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Mark Berman, a professor of psychology at the University of Chicago, where he heads the environmental neuroscience laboratory. Dr. Berman's research uses brain imaging, behavioral experiments, and other methods to explore how our physical environments, especially nature, affect our attention, memory, and emotion. His work has been featured in media outlets including CNN, NPR, the New York Times,
这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是芝加哥大学心理学教授马克·伯曼博士，他负责环境神经科学实验室。伯曼博士的研究利用脑成像、行为实验和其他方法来探索我们的物理环境（尤其是大自然）如何影响我们的注意力、记忆力和情绪。他的工作曾在 CNN、NPR、《纽约时报》等媒体上报道，
the Wall Street Journal, and the Washington Post. His new book is called Nature and the Mind, the Science of How Nature Improves Cognitive, Physical, and Social Well-Being. Dr. Berman, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me on the program. I want to start with the study you published back in 2008. As you explain in your book, this was an experiment that helped pave the way for basically all your future research, and it has to do with just taking a walk in a park.
《华尔街日报》和《华盛顿邮报》。他的新书名为《自然与心灵：自然如何改善认知、身体和社会福祉的科学》。伯曼博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。谢谢您邀请我参加节目。我想从您 2008 年发表的一项研究开始谈起。正如您在书中所解释的那样，这是一项为您的所有未来研究铺平道路的实验，它与在公园里散步有关。
Tell us about that study and what you found. Yeah, so that study was, one of the first studies in kind of environmental psychology that looked to see if interacting with nature changed people's attention and their memory using kind of objective measures. So often people who did these studies in the past, they would kind of just ask people,
请给我们介绍一下那项研究以及您的发现。好的，那项研究是环境心理学领域最早的研究之一，它通过客观的测量方法来观察与大自然的互动是否改变了人们的注意力和记忆力。过去做这些研究的人通常只是问人们，
did you feel better after the walk in nature? And most people said yes, they felt better. But we took a more sort of quantitative approach to say, okay, but does nature actually change working memory and attention performance. So I designed a study with two of my mentors, Steve Kaplan, and John Janitas. And basically what we did is we gave participants
你在大自然中散步后感觉好些了吗？大多数人都说是的，他们感觉好多了。但我们采取了一种更量化的方法，即：好吧，但大自然真的能改变工作记忆和注意力表现吗？所以我与我的两位导师史蒂夫·卡普兰和约翰·贾尼塔斯一起设计了一项研究。基本上，我们所做的是让参与者
a challenging attention and working memory task called the backwards digit span task. And that was a task where you would hear digits out loud, like 4,8, 3, and you need to repeat them back and backwards order. So 3, 8, 4. And three digits, the task is pretty easy. But we keep increasing the number of digits
完成一项具有挑战性的注意力和工作记忆任务，称为“倒序数字广度任务”。这是一项任务，你会听到大声读出的数字，比如 4、8、3，你需要倒序重复它们。也就是 3、8、4。三个数字时，任务相当简单。但我们不断增加数字的数量，
it's all the way up to about nine digits. At around five digits, the task is pretty hard. So we gave participants this backwards digit span task, and then we gave them a map to go on a walk in a more natural environment. This was the Ann Arbor Arboretum near the University of Michigan campus. Or we had people walk on a more urban path
一直增加到大约九个数字。在大约五个数字时，任务就变得相当困难了。所以我们让参与者完成这个倒序数字广度任务，然后给他们一张地图，让他们去一个更自然的自然环境中散步。这是密歇根大学校园附近的安娜堡植物园。或者我们让人们在更城市化的路径上行走，
down busy Washina Avenue in Ann Arbor. Both walks were about 2.6 miles, and it took participants about 50-50 minutes to complete the walks. And then after the walk, they returned to the lab and they took this backwards digit span task again. We also did two important things too before participants went on the walk.
沿着安娜堡繁忙的华盛顿大道。两次散步的路程大约都是 2.6 英里，参与者大约需要 50 分钟才能完成。散步结束后，他们回到实验室，再次进行这个倒序数字广度任务。在参与者去散步之前，我们也做了两件重要的事情。
So one thing is we gave participants a GPS watch so that we could track them. So he made sure that they didn't just go to Starbucks that they actually went on the walk. And then we also used the GPS traces to make sure that people didn't get lost because we thought if people got lost, maybe the walk wouldn't be very beneficial.
第一件事是，我们给参与者戴上 GPS 手表，这样我们就可以追踪他们。所以我们确保他们没有只是去星巴克，而是真的去散步了。然后我们还利用 GPS 轨迹来确保人们没有迷路，因为我们认为如果人们迷路了，也许散步就不会那么有益，
they might be too stressed out. And then we also took participants' cell phones. So we kept their cell phones in the lab. We didn't want them sort of chit-chatting and texting on the walk. We wanted them to be really, really engaged with the natural environment or the urban environment when they went on those walks. So participants, they take this backwards digit span task. Then they either go for a walk in nature or they go for a walk in an urban environment.
他们可能会感到压力过大。然后我们还收走了参与者的手机。所以我们将他们的手机留在实验室里。我们不希望他们在散步时聊天或发短信。我们希望他们在散步时真正地沉浸在自然环境或城市环境中。所以参与者先完成这个倒序数字广度任务。然后他们要么去大自然中散步，要么去城市环境中散步。
They come back to the lab. They take this backwards digit span task again. And then they return to the lab a week later. and repeat the whole procedure again. But if they walked in the natural environment the first week, they walked in the urban environment the second week or vice versa. So everybody was their own control.
他们回到实验室。他们再次进行这个倒序数字广度任务。然后他们一周后回到实验室，重复整个过程。但如果他们第一周是在自然环境中散步，那么第二周他们就在城市环境中散步，反之亦然。所以每个人都是自己的对照组。
And what we found was pretty amazing that participants improved by about 20% on this difficult attention and memory task, this backwards digit span task after they walked in nature, but they really didn't show any improvement after they went on the urban walk. And we thought, wow, this is a pretty cool finding. That's quite significant. So let me ask you, why did this work? Why would just taking a walk in a park as opposed to on city streets help people do better on a cognitive test?
我们发现的结果非常惊人：参与者在自然环境中散步后，在这项困难的注意力和记忆任务（即倒序数字广度任务）上的表现提高了约 20%，但他们在城市散步后并没有表现出任何改善。我们想，哇，这是一个非常酷的发现。这相当显著。那么请问，为什么会这样？为什么在公园里散步而不是在城市街道上散步能帮助人们在认知测试中表现得更好？
Well, we think it has to do with attention. And I mentioned that I did this work in collaboration with Stephen Kaplan and John Janitas. And Steve Kaplan had developed a theory called attention restoration theory that basically posits that humans have two kinds of attention. and that our attention could be kind of restored or replenished with different kinds of physical environment. So one kind of attention that Steve posited that humans have is called directed attention. And that's the kind of attention that we use at work or at school where you as an individual person are deciding what you're paying attention to. And it's thought that that kind of attention is fatigable or depletable, that you can only sort of direct your attention for so long before you become mentally fatigued. It's hard to pay attention anymore.
嗯，我们认为这与注意力有关。我提到过我与史蒂芬·卡普兰和约翰·贾尼塔斯合作完成了这项工作。史蒂夫·卡普兰提出了一个名为“注意力恢复理论”的理论，该理论基本上假设人类有两种注意力，并且我们的注意力可以通过不同类型的物理环境得到恢复或补充。史蒂夫假设人类拥有的第一种注意力称为“定向注意力”。这就是我们在工作或学校中使用的那种注意力，作为个人，你决定你正在关注什么。人们认为这种注意力是容易疲劳或耗尽的，你只能在精神疲劳之前引导你的注意力一段时间。很难再集中注意力了。
And we've all had that sensation, like at the end of a long workday where you might be looking at the computer screen and you're just kind of staring at the screen and you're not able to get anything done. You're kind of mind wandering. It's hard to focus. That's what we call a directed attention fatigue. That's when we think it would be a good time to take a break.
我们都有过那种感觉，比如在漫长的工作日结束时，你可能盯着电脑屏幕，只是盯着屏幕，却什么也做不成。你的思绪在游离。很难集中注意力。这就是我们所说的“定向注意力疲劳”。这就是我们认为休息一下的好时机。
That's different from involuntary attention, which is the kind of attention that we think is automatically captured by interesting stimulation in the environment. So bright lights, loud noises, those things automatically capture our attention. And it thought that that's sort of less susceptible to fatigue or depletion. So you don't often hear people say, oh, I can't look at that beautiful waterfall anymore. It's just so breathtaking. I'm too tired.
这与“非自愿注意力”不同，非自愿注意力是我们认为会被环境中有趣的刺激自动捕捉到的那种注意力。所以明亮的灯光、巨大的噪音，这些东西会自动捕捉我们的注意力。人们认为这种注意力不太容易疲劳或耗尽。所以你很少听到人们说，哦，我不能再看那个美丽的瀑布了。它太壮观了。我太累了。
I can't look at it anymore. Oh, I can't watch this really interesting movie anymore. It's just too interesting. I'm too tired. I have to shut it off. So the idea with attention restoration theory is that if we can find environment that don't place a lot of demands on directed attention while simultaneously having interesting stimulation to activate the involuntary attention, we could kind of restore this precious directed attention resource and we think that natural
我不能再看它了。哦，我不能再看这部非常有趣的电影了。它太有趣了。我太累了。我必须关掉它。所以注意力恢复理论的观点是，如果我们能找到那些不对定向注意力提出太多要求，同时又具有有趣的刺激来激活非自愿注意力的环境，我们就能恢复这种宝贵的定向注意力资源，我们认为自然
environments are one kind of environment that can do this. It doesn't mean that nature is the only environment that can do this, but we think that many natural environments think your local park where you feel safe where there's interesting things to look at. You don't have to place a lot of demands on directed attention, but they have interesting stimulation. to activate the involuntary attention. There's one other thing too that I want to mention also, which is that we think it's important how your involuntary attention is activated.
环境就是这样一种可以做到这一点的环境。这并不意味着大自然是唯一能做到这一点的环境，但我们认为许多自然环境（想想你当地的公园，在那里你感到安全，有有趣的东西可以看）不需要对定向注意力提出太多要求，但它们有有趣的刺激来激活非自愿注意力。还有一件事我也想提一下，那就是我们认为非自愿注意力是如何被激活的很重要。
So we think that it's important to the stimulation be softly fascinating and not harshly fascinating. So to kind of explain that, again, if you see a beautiful waterfall, it captures your attention, but it doesn't really capture all of your attentional focus. You can kind of mind wander and think about other things
所以我们认为刺激必须是“柔和迷人”的，而不是“强烈迷人”的。为了解释这一点，再说一次，如果你看到一个美丽的瀑布，它会吸引你的注意力，但它并不会真正占据你所有的注意力焦点。你可以思绪游离，思考其他事情，
while you're looking at this beautiful waterfall. When I'm in Times Square, it's also really interesting. Lots of stimulation to capture my involuntary attention, but it sort of does so in an all-consuming way where I can't really think about anything else. And we don't think that that kind of attentional capture is restful. So we think that the kind of stimulation that captures your attention
当你看着这个美丽的瀑布时。当我在时代广场时，那里也非常有趣。有很多刺激来捕捉我的非自愿注意力，但它以一种全盘占据的方式做到这一点，以至于我无法真正思考任何其他事情。我们认为那种注意力捕捉并不是放松的。所以我们认为那种捕捉你注意力的刺激
needs to be softly fascinating, and again, natural environments tend to have softly fascinating stimulation. And is it mostly about the visual stimulation? I mean, what about the other things that are happening when you're in nature, whether that smells or sounds, bird calls? I mean, how might that affect your attention? Yeah, we think it's definitely multimodal.
需要是柔和迷人的，同样，自然环境往往具有柔和迷人的刺激。这主要是关于视觉刺激吗？我的意思是，当你身处大自然中时，其他正在发生的事情（无论是气味还是声音，鸟鸣）又如何呢？我的意思是，这可能会如何影响你的注意力？是的，我们认为这绝对是多模态的。
So when you're actually out on the real walk in nature, you're getting the visual, you're getting the auditory stimulation. You might be getting the tactile stimulation. You might be getting the olfactory, the smell stimulation. So it's all, all those things are at play. We have done studies where we show people just pictures of nature or nature videos and where it's just a visual stimulation, in particular the pictures. And we find you can get some similar benefits just looking at pictures of nature versus pictures of urban scenes,
所以当你真正走在大自然中时，你得到了视觉刺激，得到了听觉刺激。你可能会得到触觉刺激。你可能会得到嗅觉刺激。所以所有这些东西都在起作用。我们做过一些研究，向人们展示大自然的照片或自然视频，其中只有视觉刺激，特别是照片。我们发现，仅仅看大自然的照片与看城市场景的照片相比，你也能获得一些类似的好处，
which suggests that it's something about the visual patterns of nature. But we've also had people listen to nature sounds versus urban sounds. And we get similar benefits there. So there's something about the acoustic properties of nature, the entropy, the spectral profile that might be easier for our brains to process. We haven't yet tested the olfactory properties, although I have a colleague Leslie Kaye, who's an expert on olfaction, and she's been talking to me about terpenes, this molecular compound that's found in nature smells and primarily good nature smells. maybe there's something about ingesting turpines, but we've focused more on the visual and the auditory, in part because it's easier.
这表明大自然视觉模式的某些东西起到了作用。但我们也让人们听自然声音与城市声音。我们在那里也得到了类似的好处。所以大自然的声学特性、熵、频谱分布可能更容易被我们的大脑处理。我们还没有测试嗅觉特性，尽管我有一位同事莱斯利·凯，她是嗅觉方面的专家，她一直在和我谈论萜烯，这是一种在自然气味中发现的分子化合物，主要是好的自然气味。也许摄入萜烯有什么好处，但我们更多地关注视觉和听觉，部分原因是这更容易。
But it's possible that all of these different modalities are at play. And importantly, even though we find effects of looking at pictures of nature and listening to nature sounds, which I think is important because lots of people don't have easy access to nature, we don't view that as a replacement for real nature. And we find that the effects from looking at pictures of nature or listening in nature sounds are not as strong as actually going out in nature.
但所有这些不同的模态都有可能在起作用。重要的是，尽管我们发现了看大自然照片和听自然声音的效果，我认为这很重要，因为很多人无法轻易接触到大自然，但我们并不认为这是真实大自然的替代品。我们发现，看大自然照片或听自然声音的效果不如真正走进大自然中那么强烈。
So going out in real nature is the best, but if you can't do it, if you don't have access or if you don't have time, it's good to know that you can get some of these benefits from these simulations of nature. So I get how you could do neuroimaging while people are in a lab looking at pictures or listening to sounds.
所以走进真实的大自然是最好的，但如果你做不到，如果你没有机会或没有时间，知道你可以从这些大自然的模拟中获得一些好处是件好事。所以我明白你如何在实验室里让人们看照片或听声音时进行神经成像。
But what about people who are actually in nature? I mean, how can you measure what's happening in their brains? Can you? Now we can. And, you know, we don't have, results yet, but we've started to collect data. There now is a mobile brain imaging technology called functional near infrared spectroscopy or fnors, and that's a little cap that people wear
但那些真正身处大自然中的人呢？我的意思是，你如何测量他们大脑中正在发生的事情？可以吗？现在我们可以了。而且，你知道，我们还没有结果，但我们已经开始收集数据了。现在有一种移动脑成像技术，称为功能性近红外光谱（fNIRS），那是人们戴的一种小帽子，
that shines infrared light into the brain, and then you can record how oxygenated the blood is, which is kind of similar to the mechanism for fMRI, functional magnetic resonance imaging, which has been a very prominent neuroimaging tool in psychology and in cognitive neuroscience. But as many of you know, being an MRI scanner is not a very restful experience. It's very tight. If you have claustrophobia, you can't go in. There's that noise that you're hearing boom, boom, boom, boom through the whole thing. Yeah.
它将红外光照射到大脑中，然后你可以记录血液的含氧量，这与 fMRI（功能性磁共振成像）的机制有点相似，fMRI 一直是心理学和认知神经科学中非常突出的神经成像工具。但正如你们许多人所知，待在 MRI 扫描仪里并不是一种非常放松的体验。它非常狭窄。如果你有幽闭恐惧症，你就进不去。你会听到那种砰、砰、砰、砰的声音。是的。
They keep your head really, really still. So it's not a very restful place to be. be testing how different environments can be restful to the brain. But luckily, with this functional near-infrared spectroscopy, we can actually have people go out in real nature and real urban environments, record signals from their brain to see we have some ideas that, you know, maybe we'll find signatures of the brain sort of being in a more rested state when people walk in nature versus a more urban environment. Let's talk about different natural environments for a minute.
他们让你的头保持得非常非常静止。所以这不是一个非常放松的地方，无法测试不同的环境如何对大脑起到放松作用。但幸运的是，有了这种功能性近红外光谱，我们实际上可以让人们走进真实的大自然和真实的城市环境中，记录他们大脑的信号，看看我们有一些想法，你知道，也许我们会发现当人们在大自然中行走时，大脑处于更放松状态的特征，而不是在更城市化的环境中。让我们谈谈不同的自然环境。
You know, I spent 18 years living on a lake, and I came to believe that just looking at the water every day made me feel better. What does the research say about experiencing these blue spaces near the water or other outdoor spaces? Yeah, it's a good question. People find benefits from these green spaces, so kind of more forest kind of spaces, but people also find benefits from blue spaces, you know, interacting or being. near lakes or the ocean even. And again, I think that makes sense. Again, if we think about the fact that you can get benefits
你知道，我在湖边住了 18 年，我开始相信每天看着水面让我感觉更好。研究对于体验这些水边的“蓝色空间”或其他户外空间有什么说法？是的，这是一个好问题。人们从这些绿色空间（即更像森林的空间）中获得好处，但人们也从蓝色空间中获得好处，你知道，与湖泊或海洋互动或待在附近。再说一次，我认为这说得通。再说一次，如果我们考虑到你可以从大自然的照片和自然声音中获得好处，这表明大自然的审美或大自然的感知特性可能有所贡献。所以，例如，视觉上的自然刺激
from the pictures of nature and nature sounds suggest that there's something about the aesthetic of nature or the perceptual properties of nature that might contribute. So, for example, natural stimulation visually
比城市刺激具有更高的分形性。我所说的分形性是指，如果你想象一片雪花，它有一个形状，一个特征形状。如果你把那片雪花放在显微镜下，在显微镜下放大，你会看到一些相同的形状。如果你放大得更多，
has like higher fractalness than urban stimulation. And what I mean by fractalness is if you imagine a snowflake, it's got a shape, a characteristic shape. And if you put that snowflake under the microscope, under a microscope and zoomed in, you would see some of the same shape. And if you zoomed in even more,
你会看到一些相同的形状。无论你从什么尺度、什么空间尺度观察雪花，它都有相同的特征形状。这被称为分形或无标度。无论你从什么尺度观察刺激，它都有相同的特征形状。大自然充满了这种分形
you would see some of that same shape. That it doesn't matter what scale, what spatial scale you look at the snowflake, it's got the same characteristic shape. So that's called fractal or scale free. That it doesn't matter what scale you look at the stimulus. it's got the same characteristic shape. And nature is kind of filled with this fractal
或无标度刺激。所以你可以想象一棵树。一棵树有一个树干，分叉成大树枝，大树枝分叉成更小的树枝，它们分叉成更小的树枝，分叉成叶子。然后叶子的叶脉，你知道，分叉的叶脉。在树的不同尺度上都有相同的分叉结构。人们真的很喜欢看分形刺激。而且我们的脑部可能更流畅地处理这种刺激。无论你是在看森林还是海洋场景，它们往往都具有一些相同的分形结构。我们认为声音方面也发生了类似的事情。所以，你知道，鸟鸣、海浪拍打。这些自然声音往往具有一些相同的声学
or scale-free stimulation. So you can imagine a tree. A tree has got a trunk that branches out into big branches that branch out into smaller branches, and they branches out into smaller branches, which branches out into leaves. Then the veins have leaves that, you know, veins that branch out. There's the same kind of bracking structure
特性，我们认为与你在城市环境中发现的其他一些刺激相比，我们的大脑可能更流畅地处理这些特性。比如想象一下汽车喇叭声或汽车警报声。没有人会说那种声学刺激听起来令人愉悦或真正放松。你需要在大自然中待多长时间才能获得这些好处？如果是在非常野生的环境中，或者只是在修剪整齐的花园里，这有关系吗？是的，这些是非常非常好的问题。不幸的是，我的简短回答是我们还不知道关于那一切的一切。
at different scales of the tree. And people really like looking at fractal stimulation. and it may be also the case that our brains might process that stimulation more more fluently. And whether you're looking at a forest or an ocean scene, they both tend to have some of the same fractal kind of structure to them. And we think there are similar things happening with the sound. So, you know, bird song, waves crashing. These natural sounds tend to have some of the same accrued.
还有很多工作要做。已经有研究表明，就与大自然的互动而言，你需要互动多少才能获得好处？有些人说你每周需要与大自然互动大约两个小时。我们发现 50 分钟的自然散步有效，但人们发现更短的自然散步也可能有效，比如 30 分钟或 20 分钟。当我们让人们观看大自然的照片时，那是大约 10 分钟。听大自然的声音也是一样。我们让人们听大自然的声音大约 10 分钟。我的第一反应
properties that we think our brains might process more more fluently compared to some other kinds of stimulation you'd find in an urban environment. Like imagine a car horn honking or a car alarm going off. Nobody would say that that kind of acoustic stimulation is pleasant to listen to or really restful to listen to. Is there a certain amount of time you need to spend in nature to get these benefits? And does it matter if it's in a really wild? environment or maybe you're just in a manicured garden. Yeah, those are really, really great questions. And unfortunately, my short answer is we don't know everything yet about that.
是说越多越好。而且我认为你需要在大自然环境中待足够长的时间，让你感觉自己好像远离了日常生活。但是，你知道，我们确实认为，即使你只有五分钟，也许听五分钟的自然声音也会有一些好处。但我们确实认为，你与大自然互动的时间越长越好。我们不太了解的另一件事是某种累积效应。
There's still a lot of work to be done. There has been research to suggest that in terms of interacting with nature, how much would you need to interact to get the benefits? Some people say you want to interact with nature about two hours a week. We've found that the 50-minute walk in nature works, but people have found that shorter walks in nature could work, like 30 minutes or 20. 20 minutes. When we have people view the pictures of nature, that's for about 10 minutes. Same thing for listening to nature. We had people listen to nature for about 10 minutes. I would, my knee-jerk
所以如果你每周在大自然中待两个小时，你知道，连续 10 周，那效果如何？我们不知道这个问题的答案，部分原因是这些研究很难做，但它们是我们必须做的必要研究。作为一个领域，我们只是还没有做过。我们要休息一下。回来后，我们将讨论你是否必须喜欢在大自然中度过时光才能从中受益，
response is to say more is better. And I think you want to have enough time in the natural environment that you kind of feel like you're kind of away from your day to day. But, you know, we do think that kind of, even if you only had five minutes, maybe listening to five minutes of nature sounds would have some benefit. But we do think the longer that you can interact with the nature, the better. Another thing that we don't really know is sort of like the cumulative effects.
以及将植物和自然场景等自然元素带入你的家中是否有帮助。你的夏天现在从家得宝的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Next Grill 四炉燃气烤架来开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅来招待客人，仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝获得低价保证。
So if you spend two hours in nature a week, you know, for 10 weeks in a row, how good is that? And we don't know the answer to that in part because those are hard studies to do, but there are necessary studies that we need to do. We just haven't done them yet as a field. We're going to take a short break. When we return, we'll talk about whether you have to enjoy spending time in nature to benefit from it,
售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款，详情请参阅 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步。我们省了多少钱？足够了。
and about whether it's helpful to bring natural elements like plants and nature scenes into your home. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed
足够去迷路了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。离水边只有几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开始。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可节省 20%，获得你期待的住宿。当你想要节省开支，而不是惊喜时。你住在哪里很重要。希尔顿，为了住宿。所以很多人并不认为自己特别喜欢户外活动。也许他们喜欢在美丽的 70 度天气里散步，但当天气寒冷或下雨时，他们想待在室内。即使你在雨中散步，而且并不是真的很喜欢它，你仍然能获得大自然的好处吗？是的，绝对可以。
at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th U.S. only exclusions apply, see Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough.
我认为这是更违反直觉的发现之一。所以每个人都说，哦，好吧，马克，你知道，是的，大自然对我们有好处。我们喜欢大自然。所以大自然可能会改善，你知道，注意力和工作记忆并不令人惊讶。但从散步研究（最初的散步研究）中真正有趣的是，我们让人们在一年中的不同时间散步。所以有些人是在六月散步的，当时安娜堡的气温在 80 华氏度左右，人们真的很喜欢这次散步。我说，马克，我不敢相信你付钱让我去大自然中散步。喜欢自然散步，表现出了非常健康的注意力和记忆力益处。
Enough to get lost. Or you could book a lot. stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. So a lot of people don't consider themselves particularly outdoorsy. Maybe they like taking a walk on a beautiful 70-degree day, but they want to stay inside when it's cold or raining. Can you still get the benefits of nature, even if you're taking a walk in the rain and you're not really loving it? Yes, absolutely.
我们还让人们在一月散步，当时气温在 25 华氏度左右，人们说，马克，我不喜欢那次散步。我在外面冻得要命。他们在在一月散步时没有表现出情绪上的好处，但他们表现出了与六月散步的人相同的记忆力和注意力益处。所以你甚至不需要喜欢自然散步就能获得这些认知益处。
I think this is one of the more counterintuitive findings. So everybody says, oh, okay, Mark, you know, yeah, nature is good for us. We like nature. So it's not a surprise that nature might improve, you know, attention and working memory. But what was really interesting from the walking study, the original walking study, is that we had people walk at different times of the year. So some people walked in June when it was around 80 degrees Fahrenheit in Ann Arbor, and people really loved the walk. I said, Mark, I can't believe you're paying me to go for a walk at nature. Love the nature walk, showed really healthy attention and memory benefits.
而且我认为这非常非常重要，这不仅仅是关于喜欢。所以这不像，你知道，哦，如果我吃了一块巧克力，它让我有点快乐，我就会获得这些认知益处。这是别的东西。所以这是关于环境，物理环境如何能够以某种方式休息
We also had people walk in January when it was about 25 degrees Fahrenheit, and people said, Mark, I did not like that walk. I was freezing my butt off out there. they did not show mood benefits walking in January, but they showed the same memory and attention benefits as the people that walked in June. So you didn't even have to enjoy the nature walk to get these cognitive benefits.
我们的定向注意力，独立于情绪的变化。即使我们并不真正享受在大自然中的散步，也能获得认知益处。我想我会说这有点像吃菠菜或西兰花。你可能觉得它味道不是最好的，但它对我们有好处。现在，我要说一定有某种阈值。有时我们会有一些厚脸皮的审稿人阅读我们的论文。
And I think that's really, really important that this isn't just about liking. So it's not like, you know, oh, if I eat a piece of chocolate and it makes me a little happy that I'm going to get these cognitive benefits. This is something else. So this is something about how the environment, how the physical environment can sort of rest
他们说，好吧，那野火呢？或者如果你在大自然中被熊追赶怎么办？我们会说，当然，我们不认为那会恢复注意力，因为你将不得不使用大量的定向注意力。所以再说一次，如果你在大自然中，气温是 10 华氏度，而且你没有穿合适的外套或帽子，我们不认为这会有益。
our directed attention independent of changes in mood. And that can get a cognitive benefit, even if we don't really enjoy the walk in nature. I guess I would kind of say it's sort of like eating spinach or broccoli. You might not think it tastes the best, but it's good for us. Now, I will say that there must be some kind of threshold And sometimes we have cheeky reviewers that read our papers.
会太不舒服。但如果你的最低舒适度和需求得到了满足，你不需要真正享受自然散步就能获得益处。这很有趣。现在，有些人会利用他们的日常散步来听播客，或者也许他们会给他们一直想聊的朋友打电话。你仍然能获得大自然同样的认知和其他好处吗？还是我们需要拔掉设备的插头才能获得全部好处？是的，不幸的是，我认为你必须拔掉插头。已经有一些研究表明，如果你在散步时用手机通话，你就得不到好处。而且我认为这说得通，因为如果你在听播客，或者如果你在电话里和朋友聊天，
And they say, well, what about a wildfire? Or what if you're being chased by a bear in nature? And we'd say, of course, we don't think that's going to be restorative of attention because you're going to have to use a lot of directed attention. So again, if you're in nature and it's 10 degrees Fahrenheit, and you're not wearing a proper coat or hat, it's not, we don't think it's going to be beneficial.
你必须使用大量的定向注意力。而且你还分散了自己对我们认为柔和迷人的自然刺激的注意力。所以我们认为当你走进大自然时，真正拔掉插头非常重要。如果你想获得最大的回报，你想让你的所有非自愿注意力都被环境所捕捉。我还建议你独自去散步。所以例如，我有孩子，让我的孩子在大自然中很重要。但当我带他们去大自然时，我不把那算作我自己的自然休息。那是给他们的。
going to be too uncomfortable. But if your minimum level of comfort and needs have been met, you don't have to really enjoy the nature walk to get the benefit. That's interesting. Now, some people will use their daily walks to catch up on listening to podcasts or maybe they'll call a friend they've been meaning to talk to. Can you still get the same cognitive and other benefits of nature or do we need to unplug our devices to get the full benefit. Yeah, unfortunately, I think you got to unplug. And there's been some work that has shown that if you're talking on a cell phone while on the walk, you don't get the benefit. And I think that makes sense because if you're listening to a podcast or if you're talking to a friend of the phone,
我必须找到时间自己出去。我认为不进行任何其他类型的干扰或类似需要定向注意力的东西非常重要。你希望你的所有非自愿注意力都被那种自然刺激自动捕捉。很多人试图通过用植物或自然场景的照片或画作装饰来把大自然带入家中。甚至有一个术语叫“亲生物设计”。是否有研究表明亲生物设计确实有好处？
you're having to use a lot of directed attention. And you're also distracting yourself from the natural stimulation that we think is softly fascinating. So we think it's really important that you actually unplug when you go into nature. If you want to get the most bang for your buck, you want to allow all of your involuntary attention to be captured by the environment. And I would also advocate that you go for the walk by yourself. So for example, I have kids and it's important for my kids to be out in nature. But when I take them out in nature, I don't, count that as a nature break for me. That's for them.
我们在这里谈论的是什么样的装饰手法？是的，这也是一个非常好的问题。是的，人们发现将自然刺激带入家庭环境是有好处的，即使它是人工的。所以，你知道，我们谈论这些效果的不同层次。所以最好的事情是如果你能走进真实的大自然，那么第二好的事情是，你是否有真实大自然的视野？那可能很好。但如果你没有真实大自然的视野，你可以把植物，真实的植物带进你的办公室。但如果你没有好的自然光，你可以放假植物。所以例如，我现在办公室里我身后有一株植物，那是一株假植物，因为我办公室里没有好的自然光。人们发现
And I have to find time to go out on my own. I think it is really important to not have any other kind of distraction or things like that that are going to be requiring directed attention. You want all of your involuntary attention to be kind of automatically captured by that natural stimulation. A lot of people try to bring nature into their homes by decorating with plants or photos or paintings of natural scenes. And there's even a term for this biophilic design. Is there research that shows that there are actual benefits from biophilic
在医院和不同的环境中，拥有假植物、假绿植可以产生一些相同的好处。我不知道有关于用人造自然改善认知功能的研究，但肯定能改善情绪，提高平静感，即使是假大自然也能有益。然后你也提出了亲生物模式的想法。所以人们谈论模仿大自然的模式。所以你可以想象地毯具有大自然的一些弯曲边缘结构，但实际上并不是明显的自然。人们发现即使那样也能产生一些好处。
design? And what kinds of decorating touches are we talking about here? Yes, that's a really good question too. And yes, people have found benefits from bringing natural stimulation into their home environments, even if it's artificial. So, you know, we kind of talk about different layers of these effects. So the best thing is if you can go on into real nature, then like the second best thing is, do you have a view to real nature? That can be good. But if you don't have a view to real nature, you can bring maybe plants, real plants into your office. But if you don't have good natural light, you can have fake plants. So for example, I have a plant behind me right now in my office, that's a fake plant because I don't have good natural light in my office. And people have found
我们在一些关于与大自然互动如何改变人们思考内容的研究中也发现了这一点。所以我们与一个名为 TKF 基金会的私人基金会进行了一项研究。现在它叫“自然神圣”。这个基金会建造了大约 150 个公园，主要在巴尔的摩、华盛顿特区、安纳波利斯、马里兰地区。
that, you know, in hospitals and different settings, having fake plants, fake greenery can have some of these same benefits. I don't know of studies about improving cognitive functioning with the artificial nature, but definitely improving mood, improving calmness, having even fake nature can be beneficial. And then you also brought up this idea of biophilic patterns. So people have talked about mimicking the patterns of nature. So you can imagine carpet that has some of the curved edge kind of structure of nature but doesn't actually isn't actually overtly nature. And people have found that even that can have some benefits.
所有这些公园都有一个特征性的长椅，他们称之为 TKF 长椅，下面有一篇日记条目。抱歉，是一本日记，人们坐在公园里时可以写日记条目。这个基金会实际上转录了所有这些日记条目，所以大约有 12,000 条来自坐在这些公园里的人的日记条目
And we've found that too with some research on how interacting with nature can change what people think about. So we did a study with a private foundation that was called the TKF Foundation. Now it's called Nature Sacred. And this foundation built like 150 parks mostly in the Baltimore, Washington, D.C., Annapolis, Maryland area.
只是写下他们在想什么。我们感兴趣的是看看，这些公园的不同元素是否会影响人们写的内容。所以基金会也有来自这些公园的照片。所以和我的学生凯特·谢尔茨一起，我们实际上量化了这些公园图像中的不同事物
And all of these parks had a characteristic bench, a TKF bench that they called it, that had a journal entry underneath. a diary, sorry, and people could write journal entries when they're sitting in the park. And this foundation actually transcribed all of these journal entries, so they're about 12,000 journal entries from people sitting in these parks
也量化了人们写的内容。所以首先我从公园里包含的内容开始。所以凯特做的第一件事是，你知道，我们有来自所有这些公园的照片，凯特只是让人们，一组不同的参与者，所以这些在线参与者，只是评价这些公园的照片
and just writing about what they were thinking about. And what we were interested in was to see, do different elements of these parks impact what people write about. And so the foundation also had pictures from these parks. And so with my student, Kate Shirts, we actually quantified different things from these images of the parks
评价他们认为公园有多自然，有些公园，你知道，是在一个更城市化的区域，即使它们是一个公园，也有更多的城市感觉。有些感觉就像你在一个更隐蔽的自然环境中。所以它感觉更自然。然后凯特做的是她做了一种叫做“主题建模”的事情，这是一种你可以将文本转换为可量化的东西的方法。所以她运行了一个主题模型，将所有这 12,000 条日记条目分解为 10 个主题。然后凯特可以做的是，对于每一条日记条目，它与这个主题的相关程度如何？所以我们发现的主题之一与大自然有关，人们在写与大自然有关的事情。
and also quantified what people were writing about. So first I'll start with what's contained in the park. So one of the first things that Kate did was, you know, we had pictures from all these parks and Kate just had people, a different group of participants, so these online participants, just rate the pictures from these parks
我的意思是，他说了一些像树或鸟或类似的东西。我们发现的第一个理智检查之一是，当人们在被评为更自然的公园里时，他们倾向于写更多与自然性相关的主题。所以那是一个很好的标准检查，非常有趣。更疯狂的事情是，凯特还使用了一些计算机视觉算法来量化在这些不同的公园里有多少弯曲的边缘或弯曲的边缘。她发现如果公园里有更多的曲线和弯曲的边缘，人们更有可能写关于与灵性和他们的人生旅程相关的主题。所以那非常有趣。但非常相关。你知道，再说一次，我们没有操纵任何东西。
for how natural they thought, the parks were in some of the parks, you know, were in kind of a more urbany kind of area and had more of an urban feel, even though they were a park. And some felt like you were in more of a secluded natural environment. So it felt more natural. And then what Kate did is she did something called topic modeling, which is a way that you can convert text into something quantifiable. So she ran a topic model that kind of broke down all these 12,000 journal entries into 10 topics. And then what Kate could do was then say for each journal entry, how much did it relate to this topic? And so one of the topics that we found was related to nature, that people were writing about things related to nature.
但后来凯特做的是，她进行了另一项研究，她操纵了人们正在看的图片中弯曲边缘的数量，然后让参与者选择什么主题与图像相匹配，如果图像有更多的弯曲边缘，人们更有可能选择与灵性和他们的人生旅程相关的主题。所以那是实验性的。
I mean, he said something like tree or bird or things like that. And one of the first sanity checks we found is that when people were in parks that were rated as more natural, they tended to write more about topics related to naturalness. So that was a good standard check and pretty interesting. An even wilder thing was, is that Kate also used some computer vision algorithms to quantify in these different parks how many curved edges or curved edges. And she found that if the park had more curved lines in and her curved edges, people were more likely to write about topics related to spirituality and their life journey. So that was pretty interesting. but very correlational. You know, again, we're not manipulating anything.
但后来它变得更疯狂了，她打乱了场景。所以现在你拿这张大自然的图像，你有所有的边缘，所以你可以看到树木。但然后她打乱了边缘，所以你再也看不出它是什么了。它里面有所有的边缘，但它们都被打乱了。它看起来有点像杰克逊·波洛克的画。凯特发现，即使在这些被打乱的图像中，如果它们里面有更多的弯曲边缘，人们，它导致人们更多地思考灵性和他们的人生旅程。所以那是一条非常迂回的路线，基本上是说如果你
But then what Kate did was, as she ran another study, where she manipulated the amount of curved edges that were in pictures that people were looking at and then had participants pick what topic went with the image and if the image had more curved edges, people were more likely to pick the topic that was related to spirituality in their life journey. So that was experimental.
但后来凯特做的是，她进行了另一项研究，她操纵了人们所看图片中曲线边缘的数量，然后让参与者选择与图像相关的主题。如果图像有更多的曲线边缘，人们更有可能选择与他们人生旅程中灵性相关的主题。所以那是实验性的。
But then it got even crazier where she scrambled the scene. So now you take this image of nature and you've got all the edges so you can see the trees. But then she scrambles the edges so you can't tell what it is anymore. It's got all the edges in there, but they're all scrambled up. It kind of looks like a Jackson Pollock painting. And what Kate found was that even in these scrambled images, if they had more curved edges in them, people, it caused people to think more about spirituality in their life journey. So that was a very sort of circuitous route to basically say that if you
但后来情况变得更疯狂了，她把场景打乱了。所以现在你拿这张自然图像，你拥有所有的边缘，所以你可以看到树木。但随后她打乱了边缘，让你看不出那是什么了。它包含了所有的边缘，但它们都被打乱了。它看起来有点像杰克逊·波洛克的画。凯特发现，即使在这些被打乱的图像中，如果它们包含更多的曲线边缘，也会促使人们更多地思考他们人生旅程中的灵性。所以这是一个非常迂回的路线，基本上是为了说明如果
have curved edges, biophilic kind of architecture in your home or in your carpeting or on your wallpaper, it might cause you to think more about topics related to spirituality in your life journey. Wow, that's pretty amazing. Quite an experiment. Has this research changed the choices you've made in your own life, like in terms of where you live or how you spend your free time? Yeah, absolutely. So we, we perfectly chose, we bought a house that was close to two nature trails, even though maybe it was a little bit of a smaller house compared to another house that we could have bought that would have been bigger, but it would have been not so close to these nature trails and also closer to more car traffic. So we were very cognizant about that. We definitely
拥有曲线边缘、亲近自然的建筑风格，无论是在家中、地毯上还是壁纸上，都可能会让你更多地思考与人生旅程中灵性相关的话题。哇，这太神奇了。真是一项了不起的实验。这项研究是否改变了你自己的生活选择，比如你居住的地方或度过闲暇时光的方式？是的，绝对改变了。我们非常慎重地选择并购买了一栋靠近两条自然步道的房子，尽管相比我们本可以买到的另一栋更大的房子，这栋房子可能小了一些，但那栋房子离自然步道没那么近，而且离车流更近。所以我们对此非常有意识。我们绝对
have brought more real plants into our home. So we have a big bay window in the front of our house and we have some big plants there. As I mentioned before in my office, I don't have good natural light, but I have fake plants in my office. And then also too, when I'm working, if I feel like I'm getting kind of mentally fatigued, I don't scroll the internet or serve the internet or scroll my, well, I don't even have social media. I don't get on my cell phone. I try to go out and go for a walk in nature. And I think I know, again, I have the luxury.
在家里摆放了更多的真植物。我们房子前有一个大凸窗，我们在那里放了一些大植物。正如我之前提到的，在我的办公室里，虽然没有良好的自然光，但我放了假植物。此外，当我工作时，如果我觉得精神疲惫，我不会上网浏览，也不会刷社交媒体——好吧，我甚至没有社交媒体。我不会玩手机。我尽量走出去，去大自然中散步。我想我知道，再次强调，我拥有这种奢侈。
You know, my schedule is pretty flexible that I can do that. But I think this is important for people to consider that when you are feeling mentally fatigued, it's not always such a good idea to try to power through. It might be a better idea to try to take a break. And the kind of break that we think is going to be really beneficial, a break in nature. What are the implications of this research for policymakers and urban planners and other people who make decisions that shape town, cities, neighborhoods? And does the trend toward these mixed use developments, which are kind of a big thing where I happen to live, is that a good
你知道，我的时间表相当灵活，可以做到这一点。但我认为这一点很重要，人们需要考虑到，当你感到精神疲惫时，试图硬撑并不总是一个好主意。尝试休息一下可能是一个更好的主意。而我们认为真正有益的休息方式，就是在大自然中休息。这项研究对政策制定者、城市规划者以及其他做出塑造城镇、城市和社区决策的人有什么启示？而且，这种混合用途开发的趋势——这在我居住的地方很流行——基于你们所做的研究，这到底是好事还是坏事？
thing or a bad thing based on, you know, the research that you've done? First, I just want to say, we don't think cities are bad. We think cities are really good. So I wouldn't want anybody to take this research and say, oh, okay, let's all move out of cities and go into more rural kind of areas. No, we think cities are good for a number of reasons. In fact, we've done research to show that more populated cities have lower rates of depression per capita. More populated cities, larger cities have lower implicit racial biases. You know, so cities are great, but we want to incorporate, where we want to bring more nature into cities. So we want cities to have more parks.
首先，我只想说，我们并不认为城市不好。我们认为城市非常好。所以我不想让任何人利用这项研究说：“哦，好吧，让我们都搬出城市，去更偏远的地区吧。”不，我们认为城市在很多方面都是好的。事实上，我们已经做过研究，表明人口更稠密的城市人均抑郁率更低。人口更稠密、规模更大的城市具有更低的内隐种族偏见。所以，城市很棒，但我们希望将自然融入其中，我们希望在城市中引入更多的自然。所以我们希望城市拥有更多的公园。
And those parks have to be accessible and they have to be safe. So we've done some studies in Chicago where we had high school and college students kind of go around their neighborhood and take pictures of parks in their neighborhood and also answer some questions about parks in their neighborhood. And we found that in Chicago,
而且这些公园必须是可进入的，并且必须是安全的。我们在芝加哥做了一些研究，让高中生和大学生在他们所在的社区走动，拍摄社区公园的照片，并回答一些关于社区公园的问题。我们发现，在芝加哥，
many of the parks in the lower resource neighborhoods, these students did not feel, safe in those spaces. So it's not just enough to have the park. People have to feel safe in the park. And so we need to do all that we can to make sure that people are feeling safe and that there's good lighting and that these parks are well, well maintained to get the benefit. So it's not enough just to have the park. People need to feel safe in the park. And then, you know, there's a lot of things too. So I don't want to pick on Chicago too much. But Chicago has these. fantastic parks right by the University Chicago campus, Jackson Park, the Midway Placeants,
在许多资源匮乏的社区，学生们在这些空间里并没有感到安全。所以，仅仅拥有公园是不够的。人们必须在公园里感到安全。因此，我们需要尽一切努力确保人们感到安全，确保有良好的照明，并且这些公园得到良好的维护，才能获得益处。所以，仅仅拥有公园是不够的。人们需要在公园里感到安全。而且，你知道，还有很多其他因素。我不想过多地批评芝加哥。但芝加哥在芝加哥大学校园旁边有这些很棒的公园，比如杰克逊公园、中途广场，
and Washington Park. These parks were designed by Frederick Law Olmsted, the same landscape architect who designed Central Park in New York. But these parks in Chicago do not have the same effect as Central Park in New York. And I think part of the reason for that is that there's really a lot of car traffic that is right next to these parks. And I remember taking my kids one time walking to Jackson Park by this garden, Jackson Park called the Circle Garden, which isn't there anymore because they've built the Obama Library. And this Circle Garden was a really beautiful part of Jackson Park. And as I'm walking with my kids in Jackson Park, literally, a car was zooming by on the nearby street and a hubcap flew off of the car and just spun around in front of us.
以及华盛顿公园。这些公园是由弗雷德里克·劳·奥姆斯特德设计的，他也是纽约中央公园的景观设计师。但芝加哥的这些公园并没有产生与纽约中央公园相同的效果。我认为部分原因是这些公园旁边确实有大量的车流。我记得有一次带着孩子们步行去杰克逊公园旁边的花园，那个杰克逊公园的花园叫“圆环花园”，现在已经不存在了，因为他们建了奥巴马图书馆。这个圆环花园曾是杰克逊公园非常美丽的一部分。当我带着孩子们在杰克逊公园散步时，一辆车在附近的街道上飞驰而过，一个轮毂盖从车上飞了出来，就在我们面前旋转。
And I remember thinking, this is just such a shame when we have this great park here, but because of the car traffic and the noise, it's just not having the same effect as if we could remove that car traffic. So I think, again, too, so the parks need to be safe, but they also have to be secluded a lot of this urban stimulation that we think is taxing directed attention. So that's, I think, something that urban planners also have to have to think about. And then, you know, there's lots of creative things that we can do. For example, like imagine the skyscrapers in our cities if they had like vines growing all the way down to them.
我记得当时想，这真是太可惜了，我们有这么好的公园，但因为车流和噪音，它没有产生我们如果能消除这些车流所能达到的效果。所以我认为，同样地，公园不仅需要安全，还需要远离许多我们认为会消耗定向注意力的城市刺激。所以我认为这是城市规划者也必须考虑的事情。而且，你知道，我们可以做很多有创意的事情。例如，想象一下我们城市里的摩天大楼，如果它们上面长满了藤蔓，
Or if we had trees kind of growing out of the top of these buildings or, you know, there's a lot of creative things that we can do to try to put more nature into our cities. And I think that's something that we really want people to think about. And even another thing, too, is that the architecture, so we've done studies where architecture, that's more biophilic, that mimics more of the patterns of nature. So you can imagine gaudy buildings in Barcelona, or even on the University of Chicago campus,
或者如果这些建筑顶部生长着树木，或者，你知道，我们可以做很多有创意的事情来尝试在城市中引入更多的自然。我认为这是我们真正希望人们思考的事情。还有一点，建筑本身，我们做过研究，更亲近自然的建筑，模仿更多自然模式的建筑——你可以想象巴塞罗那高迪的建筑，甚至在芝加哥大学校园里，
we have this beautiful Gothic architecture that has all these curves to it that mimics patterns of nature. we actually find that people really prefer that kind of architecture and they actually see nature in that architecture even though there is no overt nature in it. Now, building in that way might be more expensive, but if it leads to these potential cognitive benefits, maybe it would be worth it.
我们有这种美丽的哥特式建筑，它所有的曲线都模仿了自然的模式。我们实际上发现人们非常喜欢那种建筑，即使建筑中没有明显的自然元素，他们也能在其中看到自然。现在，以这种方式建造可能更昂贵，但如果它能带来这些潜在的认知益处，也许是值得的。
So I think that's really important to think about too, versus some of the architecture that's around us that's very brutalist that just has, you know, straight lines and we find people don't really like that kind of architecture. So again, this is beyond landscape architects, but even actual architects that are building the actual structures, if they can incorporate more of these biophilic designs into their architecture, we think that can have benefits to. So just to wrap up, what's next for you? What are you working on now? What are the big questions you want to answer? So I think we definitely want to start getting direct brain
所以我认为思考这一点也非常重要，相比于我们周围一些非常粗野主义的建筑，它们只有直线，我们发现人们并不真正喜欢那种建筑。所以，这不仅是景观设计师的事，即使是建造实际结构的建筑师，如果他们能将更多这些亲近自然的设计融入到建筑中，我们认为这也会带来益处。那么总结一下，你接下来的计划是什么？你现在在研究什么？你想回答哪些重大问题？我认为我们肯定想开始获取人们与自然互动时的直接大脑测量数据。
measurements of people interacting with nature. So that's what we're doing with FNIRS now. We've started to collect data from about 20 people who have been walking in more natural environments versus more urban environments while wearing this FNIRs device. And we want to see what are the changes in the brain that are occurring when people are walking in real nature versus more built environments. We've also become very interested to try to quantify. modify what does soft fascination really mean. So we've started to look at thousands of nature and
所以这就是我们现在用功能性近红外光谱（FNIRS）所做的事情。我们已经开始从大约20人那里收集数据，他们在佩戴FNIRS设备的同时，在更自然的自然环境与更城市化的环境之间行走。我们想看看当人们在真实的自然环境中行走与在更人工的环境中行走时，大脑会发生什么变化。我们也变得非常有兴趣尝试量化“软性着迷”到底意味着什么。所以我们开始观察成千上万的自然和
urban images and analyzing them with a with a JPEG compression kind of algorithm. So JPEG compression is a means that our computers and our phones use to try to lower the amount of memory that images take up. So for example, let's say we have an image that's 100 megabytes, oftentimes what our computers and what our phones will do is compress that image down into fewer bits. And usually what that requires is kind of throwing away some information, like throwing away some of the little fine-grained details. And to our human eye, we can't tell any difference, but it saves a lot of room on our computers and on our phones. And we've been wondering, is it possible that nature scenes get compressed down into fewer
城市图像，并用一种JPEG压缩算法来分析它们。JPEG压缩是我们的电脑和手机用来尝试降低图像占用内存的一种手段。例如，假设我们有一张100兆字节的图像，我们的电脑和手机通常会做的是将该图像压缩成更少的比特。通常这需要丢弃一些信息，比如丢弃一些细微的细节。对于我们的人眼来说，我们看不出任何区别，但这为我们的电脑和手机节省了大量空间。我们一直在想，自然场景是否可能被压缩成更少的
bits than urban scenes. And it turns out that, yes, that's true. So nature scenes, the more natural the scene is, we're finding that it gets reduced to fewer bits compared to urban scenes. And maybe our brain is doing something similar. Related to that, we've also had people, tested people's memory of nature and urban scenes. So we show them a bunch of different images and then ask them later, do you remember this image or not? Did you see this image or not? And it turns, turns out people have better memory for the more urban scenes than they do for the more natural scenes. And you might think, well, Mark, that sounds like a bad thing,
比特，比城市场景更少。事实证明，确实如此。所以自然场景，场景越自然，我们发现它被压缩成的比特数就越少，相比于城市场景。也许我们的大脑也在做类似的事情。与此相关，我们也测试了人们对自然和城市场景的记忆。我们向他们展示了一堆不同的图像，然后稍后问他们，你记得这张图像吗？你见过这张图像吗？结果发现，人们对城市场景的记忆比对自然场景的记忆更好。你可能会想，好吧，马克，这听起来像是一件坏事，
but we think it's a good thing. And we think it means that when people see the nature scene, they're not processing it as deeply, and then they're not remembering it. And so maybe it means that it's easier for our brains to process. So that's been kind of cool. And then to kind of bring it together, we're finding that part of the reason why nature scenes
但我们认为这是一件好事。我们认为这意味着当人们看到自然场景时，他们并没有进行深度处理，所以他们没有记住它。所以也许这意味着它更容易被我们的大脑处理。所以这很酷。然后总结一下，我们发现自然场景之所以
are less memorable, is because they're more compressible. So part of the reason why you don't remember the nature scenes as much is because they're more compressed down that more information is thrown away and suggesting that maybe our brains are doing some kind of JPEG-like compression on these nature scenes. That's pretty fascinating.
不那么令人难忘，是因为它们更容易被压缩。所以你对自然场景记忆不深的部分原因是因为它们被压缩得更多，丢弃了更多信息，这表明也许我们的大脑正在对这些自然场景进行某种类似JPEG的压缩。这非常迷人。
Well, Dr. Berman, I want to thank you for joining me today. I think this has been really interesting. I hope our listeners have found it interesting as well and that they're going to go out and take a walk in nature after listening to you. Absolutely. And thank you so much, Kim, for having me on the program. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology. Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
好吧，伯曼博士，我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。我认为这非常有趣。我希望我们的听众也觉得很有趣，并且希望他们在听完你的节目后会去大自然中散步。当然。也非常感谢你，金，邀请我参加这个节目。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方收听。
And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There's a new way to Sweet Green. Meet Raps, handheld, hearty, and made for life on the move. With bold, chef-crafted flavors, fresh ingredients, and over 40 grams of protein,
如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请订阅并留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·怀纳曼制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。有一种新的方式来享用Sweet Green。认识一下Raps，手持式、丰盛，专为忙碌的生活而生。拥有大胆、厨师精心调制的风味、新鲜的食材和超过40克的蛋白质，
they're built to satisfy without slowing you down. Try Raps today in the app or at order.com. Available at all participating locations. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它们旨在满足你的需求，而不会拖慢你的脚步。今天就在应用程序或order.com上尝试Raps。在所有参与活动的地点均有供应。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。